Welcome to the deep dive.
We're the show that plunges head
first into, well, the most
gripping stories, fascinating
research, really surprising
insights, all to give you the
kind of knowledge that shifts
understanding into a into real
insight.
And today, wow, we're not just
diving into a story.
We are descending, descending
into a world where even angelic
wings, they don't soar, they
decay.
It's a world where heroism, you
know, it isn't measured by glory
or triumph.
It's measured by sheer brutal
survival.
That sets a tone immediately,
doesn't it?
Survival is the peak
achievement.
Exactly our journey today takes
us right into the heart of a
place the source material
describes with this chilling
clarity quote.
In Borovia, even divine wings
rotten to bone, and the only
victories are measured by who
escapes alive.
It's a stark image, really
visceral.
Yeah, almost gothic poetry in
just how bleak it is and it
perfectly.
That's the stage for the
profound and unsettling
narrative we're about to unpack.
So today we're embarking on a
deep dive into a really gripping
narrative.
It's from the heart of a
Dungeons and Dragons campaign,
specifically a session titled
The Lucky Heresy in the Fall of
Surin Ironwood.
A specific pivotal session.
Right.
And our source material, it
comes from these riveting
excerpts from session 16 dot PDF
by Chris Abraham.
It gives us this first hand
account and also a deeply
critical analysis of everything
that happened.
So we get both the what and the
why.
Precisely.
And our mission today is clear.
We're going to uncover exactly
why this particular session was,
and this is the author's phrase,
a cruel reminder of Barovia's
unforgiving nature.
We'll explore or the tragic
downfall of a hero, Sir in
Ironwood.
We'll try to understand the
thematic undercurrents that make
the story just so compelling and
so bleak.
And crucially, we want to
extract the key lessons here
about narrative, about strategy,
and about the, well, the
profound subversion of classic
heroic tropes we see playing
out.
It sounds like a session that
really crystallizes the essence
of the setting.
I think so.
So if you've ever found yourself
wrestling with, you know, high
stakes decisions, or maybe felt
that crushing weight of
circumstance bearing down, this
is for you.
This deep dive is about
understanding not just what
happened, but how and why.
Why even the most powerful
individuals can be utterly
undone by an environment that
seems to actively work against
them.
It's about the system versus the
individual.
In a way, exactly.
Peeling back the layers to find
the why behind what looks like
an inevitable failure, and what
that tells us about resilience,
about the true cost of heroism,
and that intricate dance between
player agency and narrative
design in a world that just
refuses to play by the rules.
What immediately strikes me
about this, this setup is how it
foregrounds that central
conflict you mentioned, the very
nature of heroism against a
backdrop designed to dismantle
it.
It's not just an adventure
story.
It feels more like a
philosophical confrontation.
This isn't your typical fantasy
quest, you know, where good
triumphs over evil just because
it's good.
No happily ever after guaranteed
here.
Not at all.
Understanding that fundamental
shift in expectations is
absolutely crucial for
appreciating the, well, the raw,
almost uncomfortable truths this
session really reveals.
That's a powerful way to put it.
OK, so let's immerse ourselves.
Let's set the stage.
Welcome listeners to Borovia, a
land that truly defines its own
unique brand of horror, and to
the iron grip of a city called
Valaki.
Indeed, Borovia.
It isn't just a location in a
game manual.
It is, in so many ways, a
character itself defined by this
pervasive curse.
The source calls it a cursed
valley within the Curse of
Straud campaign.
Which, I mean, it's widely
regarded as one of D and DS most
iconic gothic horror settings.
Oh good reason.
So it's not just a backdrop,
it's active.
It's active, yes.
This isn't merely a place where
monsters happen to lurk.
It feels like a sentient,
malevolent entity.
The very air feels heavy with
sorrow, with dread and almost
tangible sense of despair.
Every rustle of leaves, every
distant howl you hear, every mis
shrouded peak you see, it all
reinforces this pervasive sense
of inescapable doom.
And the source gives us this
brilliant chilling analogy for
Borovia.
It describes it as basically
Transylvania meets The Truman
Show, run by a vampire overlord.
Chuckles lightly.
That's quite the mash up.
Isn't it?
When I first read that, my mind
just, boom, conjured the classic
gothic stuff, right?
Swirling mists, ancient
crumbling castles, shadowed
forests where you know ancient
evil stir that quintessential
Transylvanian dread.
But then you add the Truman Show
element and suddenly it's not
just a scary place.
It's a place where you're always
being watched, always performing
for some unseen, omniotent
audience.
Your reality itself feels
manipulate.
Like an elaborate stage
production.
Yeah, with you as the unwilling
star, what does that blend evoke
for you?
I mean that psychological
burden, the constant
surveillance, knowing your
choices might be dictated, What
does that do to someone trapped
there?
That analogy is incredibly
insightful.
You're right.
It captures that overarching
theme of control, of inescapable
fate that just defines Borovia.
Transylvania meets The Truman
Show.
It's not just evocative
freezing, it's a precise
dissection of Barovia's unique
horror.
How so?
Well, the vampire overlord
Strad.
He isn't just some powerful
enemy you fight at the end.
He's the architect of this
entire existence.
He's the director of this
macabre play.
He doesn't merely rule the land
here.
He is the land in a sense, and
every interaction, every
perceived opportunity, it could
just be a part of his grand
tormenting design.
So nothing is what it seems.
Pretty much.
This specific blend makes it
terrifying because it
fundamentally removes the very
agency that heroes usually rely
on.
You're not just fighting a
villain, you're fighting the
entire fabric of reality.
A reality designed specifically
to ensnare you, torment you, and
ultimately break you.
Your choices often feel like
illusions.
Your triumphs are fleeting.
Your escape routes?
They might just be longer
corridors in a larger,
inescapable prison.
It strips away hope by making
even the idea of freedom feel
like it could be a carefully
orchestrated part of the show.
It leads to this profound sense
of claustrophobia and
ultimately, helplessness.
And this leads us right to this
fundamental, frankly brutal
truth about Borovia, a truth
that completely rewrites the
heroic script.
The source says it plainly.
Borovia has no patience for
heroes.
No patience.
It's not a dungeon to be
cleared, but a curse to be
survived.
What does that statement really
mean for the traditional heroic
narratives we're also used to?
How does it fundamentally alter
the stakes, the expectations,
even the definition of success?
It redefines everything
fundamentally.
In traditional heroic stories,
the goal is usually clear.
Overcome evil, defeat the
monster, restore order.
Heroes are defined by their
ability to conquer, right?
Bring light Into Darkness.
Achieve some glorious victory.
A classic arc.
Exactly.
But in Barovia, the very concept
of victory is inverted.
You're not meant to win in that
conventional sense.
You're meant to endure.
You're meant to survive another
day.
Maybe protect what little
innocence remains.
Simply make it to the next
sunrise against frankly
impossible odds.
Some success is just.
Continuing, continuing.
Yeah, This shifts the narrative
focus dramatically away from
glory and triumph towards
resilience, attrition, and that
desperate, often morally
ambiguous struggle for self
preservation.
It teaches you that sometimes
the bravest thing you can do
isn't to fight a losing battle
head on.
Sometimes it's to run, to hide,
to make compromises that would
be unthinkable anywhere else.
That's tough for a hero
character.
It's a profound subversion of
what we typically expect from a
hero.
It forces both the characters
and us, the audience, to re
evaluate what true strength and
courage look like in a world
where the deck is just
perpetually stacked against you.
It's about surviving a marathon
of psychological and physical
attrition, not sprinting to a
glorious finish line.
OK, so against this backdrop,
this pervasive, soul crushing
dread, there was Valaki.
Once Upon a time.
It was a beacon, right?
A glimmer of light, a promise of
something, well, less terrible.
Relatively speaking, yes.
The source describes it as once
the only semi safe haven.
It had high walls, bustling
Taverns, markets that sold more
than despair.
It sounds almost idyllic in
comparison, doesn't it?
It really does a vital promise
of respite in an otherwise
horrifying land, a place where
people might actually breathe a
little easier or hope, however
faint, could maybe still find
purchase.
It represents possibility.
It was more than just a place.
It was a psychological anchor.
For anyone navigating Barovia.
The idea of a safe haven, a
fortified town where the mists
of Ravenloft don't quite
permeate it, offered a crucial
flicker of hope.
It's suggested that escape, or
at least temporary sanctuary,
was possible.
This mental image of refuge,
however small, is vital for
morale.
It provides that stark contrast
to the oppressive wilderness.
But but, as the source makes
chillingly clear, that hope is
tragically extinguished.
Vlaki's transformation isn't
just a change in leadership.
It's a profound betrayal of that
foundational promise.
It's the collapse of the one
place you thought you could
maybe find solace.
And what a betrayal it was.
We learned Vlaki's been seized
by Lady Walker.
Ah.
Yes, Lady Walker.
Explicitly called Strad's
aristocratic sycophant, and she
handed control over to her
bureaucrat enforcer, the Reeve
Ernst Larnak.
So not just a hostile takeover,
but orchestrated from the top.
Exactly.
A calculated political coup
orchestrated from the shadows by
the very entity cursing the
land.
The loss of autonomy, this
imposition of a tyrannical
regime directly serving the dark
master, it just deepens that
sense of entrapment, of
systematic oppression.
And what's truly fascinating
here, I think, is how this
transformation from safe haven
to city under martial law is
such a classic horror trope, but
it's especially potent in
Barovia.
Why there specifically?
Because the loss of safety
within what was once a refuge is
far more psychologically
devastating than just
encountering danger out in the
Wilds.
It strips away the last vestiges
of sanctuary.
It leaves characters with
nowhere truly safe to retreat,
nowhere to rest or plan.
It makes the world feel smaller,
the walls closing in.
And that psychological impact?
It's often more debilitating
than any physical threat.
The ground shifts beneath your
feet.
Exactly.
The very source of perceived
safety becomes the source of
immediate danger.
It twists comfort into a new
kind of terror.
It tells you unequivocally you
are alone and nowhere is sacred
or immune to the darkness.
And the details of this new
regime?
Utterly chilling.
The source paints this vivid,
suffocating picture.
Picture a city under martial
law, guards at every corner,
wardens in black robes casting
necrotic magic and bells of
alarm, ready to summon
reinforcements at any whiff of
trouble.
There's Madden walking into
that.
Constant surveillance.
Guards eyes tracking your every
move.
These silent, watchful figures
in black robes moving with this
eerie, almost preternatural
calm.
And then that omnipresent threat
of the bells, Always there,
always ready to shatter any
illusion of peace, to summon an
unstoppable force at the
slightest sign of dissent.
It's.
The Symphony of suppression, as
you said earlier.
Yeah, every step would feel
heavy, every glance suspicious,
every whispered word a potential
betrayal.
You wouldn't just be afraid of
monsters and alleys.
You'd be afraid of the city
itself, its laws, its enforcers,
the pervasive invisible fear.
And let's really unpack who
these wardens are, because
they're far from ordinary
guards.
The source specifies them as
devil worshipping enforcers with
Ambulus of Asmodeus.
Asmodeus the Arch Devil.
Very same.
One of the most powerful and
cunning arch devils in the
infernal hierarchy.
A master of contracts, tyranny,
the corruption of souls.
So these aren't just foot
soldiers, they are zealous
cultists imbued with dark power,
driven by infernal packs.
So it's not just political
control, it's diabolical.
Exactly.
Their presence signifies a
deeper, more insidious evil at
play.
It suggests Valaki's new order
isn't just political tyranny,
but something infirmly
sanctioned and the necrotic
magic they cast.
The source explains it as life
draining, soul rotting spells.
It's not just about inflicting
physical harm.
No, it's about spiritual decay
draining the very will to
resist, eroding not just your
hit points, but your morale,
your hope, your soul.
This sophisticated, pervasive
control backed by infernal
power, it's far more terrifying
than a simple banded camp.
It's an ideological takeover,
where the bells, the black
robes, the infernal magic, it's
all designed to ensure no
resistance takes root, and that
fear becomes the primary
currency of the city, carefully
managed, ruthlessly enforced.
So into this bleak, oppressive
landscape step our protagonists,
3 adventurers, each a distinct
personality, each with their own
strength, their own
vulnerabilities, and each about
to face the ultimate test in a
place designed to break them.
A truly compelling trio, yes.
Deliberately crafted, it seems
to highlight different aspects
of heroism and struggle in this
brutal environment.
Their individual identities,
their powers, they would
typically make them formidable,
but here they're about to
confront a reality that warps
those very strengths.
First, there's Soren Ironwood
and Aasimar Paladin.
He's described as being of
Celestial bloodline, a holy
night meant to be the Radiant
Hammer of Justice.
Classic Paladin archetype.
Absolutely.
It paints this picture of
classic unwavering heroism,
right?
An awesome R, for listeners who
might not know, is typically a
mortal imbued with a trace of
angelic essence.
Often they have physical signs
like beautiful feathered wings,
a radiant presence, beacons of
hope.
Literally walking beacons of
hope, justice, divine power,
bound by sacred oaths.
They embody everything noble and
pure in a fantasy world.
But then Borovia happens.
Yes, the Barovian twist.
These Angel wings, those
glorious symbols of his divine
heritage, they brought into
skeletal bat wings.
The source puts it so powerfully
a holy vision, but tainted like
a vampire's parody of heaven.
Can you just imagine that
profound visceral horror?
What's absolutely fascinating
here is the profound, almost
sickening symbolism of Soren's
condition.
And Asamar's wings aren't just
for show.
They're the physical
manifestation of their divine
connection, their inherent
goodness.
To have those glorious feathered
wings twist and rot into
something grotesque and
monstrous, like the skeletal bat
wings of a demon or a vampire.
It's a direct physical
representation of Bruvia's
corrupting influence, even on
the most sacred beings.
It immediately signals to the
audience, and destroying himself
that this land doesn't just
challenge heroes, it redefines
them, often by stripping away
their most cherished attributes,
turning their very essence into
a source of shame or danger.
A visual metaphor for the
Valley's power.
Exactly.
To corrupt, to make what is good
and pure fester and decay into
something abhorrent.
It raises that terrifying
question, if even the divine can
be tainted so easily, if a
paladin's very being can be
warped into a vampire's parody
of heaven, what hope is there
for mere mortals?
And the psychological toll on
Surrend.
Immense.
A holy knight whose very purpose
is to embody purity, now
physically manifesting
corruption.
Devastating.
Then we have Radley Folthorne,
Human Eldritch Knight.
He's the sardonic bruiser who
mixes steel with fire bolts.
The fighter Meege combo always
interesting.
Yeah, an eldritch knight is that
rare blend Marshall prowess and
arcane spell casting.
They can weave steel with
elemental fire, bolster defenses
with magic, fight with both
blade and spell.
I can just picture him quick wit
even quicker sword, maybe cracks
a joke or a skull often with
that mischievous glint the.
Reckless one.
Definitely.
The source calls him brave,
reckless, the kind who throws
himself at the worst odds first.
Radley sounds like the perfect
foil, you know, provides that
flash of defiance, maybe some
dark humor, but also charges
headlong into danger, perhaps a
little too eagerly sometimes.
What role does a character like
Radley usually play, and how
might Borovia challenge that?
Radley represents that raw,
visceral response to danger,
often relying on brute force in
a certain audacious courage.
In many narratives, he'd be the
one who punches through
obstacles, whose straightforward
aggression wins the day.
He's the strong arm, the
frontline brawler.
Reliable damage.
Tactical simplicity.
But Borovia's unique cruelty
often punishes that kind of
directness.
It forces even the most reckless
to confront the limits of their
aggression, their magical steal.
His effectiveness is contingent
on the kind of battle Borovia
allows, which is rarely a fair
stand up fight.
His sardonic wit might be a
coping mechanism, a way to
deflect the dread, but even that
resilience will be tested
against truly inescapable
horrors.
And rounding out the trio,
Tracidor 1/2 Elf Cleric of
Light, described as the healer
and contents.
The moral center, perhaps?
Yeah, but listen to this
dilemma.
He's desperate to keep the
others alive while trying to
argue morality in a land where
morality gets you killed.
What an unenviable position.
A cleric of light is normally a
conduit for divine healing,
protective magic, a beacon
against darkness, tending the
wounded, comforting the
afflicted, guiding with moral
certainty.
But in Borovia, that moral
compass becomes liability.
What is the role of a conscience
in a land that actively punishes
morality, where survival demands
compromises that would be
unthinkable elsewhere?
That internal conflict for
tracidor must be profound.
Tracidor's internal conflict is
incredibly poignant.
It truly exemplifies 1 of
Borovia's most insidious
torments.
In a land that actively punishes
morality, where the right thing
often leads to greater suffering
or even death, what is the role
of a conscience?
He's caught, isn't he?
Tune the pragmatic, immediate
need to keep his companions
alive, healing wounds, shielding
from necrotic energy, and the
inherent, deeply ingrained
desire to do good to uphold his
divine tenets.
A constant balancing act.
Immense psychological pressure,
forcing him to constantly
evaluate the ethical cost of
every single action.
His role as healer is vital for
physical survival, sure, but his
role is conscience.
It's almost a liability in
Barovia.
It highlights the valleys
ability to corrupt even the
purest intentions.
He's trying to hold onto the
light in a place designed to
extinguish it, and that struggle
is often far more painful, more
complex than any physical
battle.
He must constantly ask himself,
is saving a life worth a moral
compromise?
What's the true cost of survival
here?
So this unlikely trio, they find
themselves in Valaki.
Not for some grand world saving
quest, no, for something
surprisingly mundane yet still
twisted by Borovia's influence.
They were there, for one thing.
A wedding dress for the abbot's
flesh crafted bride, Vasilka.
Chuckles.
A wedding dress seems almost
whimsical.
Doesn't.
It right, but in Borovia even
whimsy is laced with horror.
It does sound deceptively
simple, but this mission
immediately connects back to
straws overarching grotesque
best influence, the Abbot.
For context, he's a powerful
celestial being, driven mad by
Barovia, driven mad, convinced
that if he can create the
perfect bride for Strad out of,
well, various body parts of sort
of Frankensteinian horror, he
can somehow break the vampire
Lord's curse.
Oh my goodness, Vasilka is a
flesh golem bride.
Essentially, yes.
So even a seemingly innocuous
task like getting a wedding
dress is never simple here.
It's steeped in the grotesque,
the desperate, the perverse
schemes of the valleys denizens,
all ultimately serving Strud's
twisted desires.
It shows how deeply the curse
permeates every aspect of life,
affecting even what should be a
symbol of joy and purity,
transforming it into an errand
of despair and madness.
It's never just about the item,
it's about the twisted purpose
behind it.
And as a source reveals, that
one thing quickly unravels.
They walked straight into
politics, heresy trials, and the
long knives of the Reeve.
No shopping trip is ever easy in
Borovia.
Laughs.
Apparently not.
It's such a sudden, jarring
shift, isn't it?
From a bizarre shopping trip to
a desperate life or death
political entanglement, all
within moments.
It perfectly encapsulates the
unpredictable, escalating nature
of danger here.
One minute you're trying to find
some lace, the next you're
fighting for your life against
devil worshipping enforcers.
Which brings us to the spark
that ignited the fire.
The moment Surin's very
presence, which should have been
awe inspiring, instead ignited a
powder keg.
Outside the Manor, maybe in
desperation, maybe defiance,
CERN manifested his angelic
wings.
Tainted wings.
The Tainted Wings.
Now, in almost any other fantasy
setting, any other campaign,
that would be a moment of pure
spectacle.
It should have been awe
inspiring, right?
A clear sign of divine
intervention.
A display of celestial power
meant to cow enemies, inspire
allies.
Absolutely the manifestation of
divine power, especially from an
Osmar paladin.
It's typically a moment of
undeniable authority and
inspiration, a clear sign of
cosmic favor.
Testament into the character's
goodness and strength.
It should command respect or at
least fearful difference.
People fall to their knees.
Guards hesitate.
All prevails.
It's a quintessential heroic
flourish, a moment of
unavailable righteousness.
But this is Borovia, and as the
Source makes devastatingly
clear, divine revelation doesn't
inspire.
It terrifies.
Instead of holy light, his wings
wittered into grotesque bone and
bat flesh, like a vampire's
parody of heaven.
The visual.
Can you imagine the visceral
horror, That visual
contradiction?
Something meant to be celestial,
glorious and said, twisting into
something monstrous and profane
right before your eyes?
It's not just a physical
transformation, it's a direct,
literal manifestation of
Borovia's corrupting power,
taking Soren's greatest blessing
and turning it into a source of
revulsion and fear, a profound
betrayal of his very nature.
This is classic Borovia
storytelling, designed to
subvert every expectation, twist
every virtue into a
vulnerability.
The profound irony here is
almost unbearable.
The powers you lean on become
the very reason people turn
against you.
Soren's greatest gift became his
noose, his very essence.
His divine connection, which
should protect him, is what
seals his doom in this benighted
land.
It highlights Borovia's
insidious nature.
It doesn't just fight you
physically.
It weaponizes your identity,
your virtues, your very nature
against you.
It turns your light into a
spotlight for your enemies,
marking you as an outsider, a
threat to its established
darkness.
So the question becomes.
It raises A crucial question for
any adventurer there, in a world
where your strengths are twisted
into weaknesses, where your
virtues are deemed heresy, how
do you even fight?
How do you even exist when your
light only casts a longer shadow
for your enemies to exploit,
leading to greater peril?
And the immediate aftermath was
swift, brutal, utterly devoid of
mercy or understanding.
The Secretary screams heretic.
The trigger word.
And then, without hesitation,
guards swarmed.
No questions asked, no trial, no
chance to explain.
Just immediate, overwhelming
force brought down on the
heretic, whose very existence,
whose display of divine essence
contradicted the dark,
tyrannical rule of Valaki.
The spark had lit the fire, all
right, but it was a fire of
persecution, not inspiration.
With Sirn's divine display
branded as heresy, the
adventurers found themselves
trapped a desperate, grinding
fight inside the Manor.
And the initial moments, they
almost offered this deceptive
sense of hope, didn't they?
A flicker of the familiar rhythm
of battle.
Right, the source mentioned some
early successes.
Yeah, Trexidor's command magic
made some guards grovel in
confusion.
Radley lit them up with fire
bolts, his reckless bravery
paying off for a moment.
And Soren, ever the dramatic
paladin even with tainted wings,
flew into the 2nd floor and
smashed through a window like
Batman.
A grand entrance.
A grand entrance that
momentarily promised Maybe an
easy victory.
Those early engagements often
lead to a false sense of
security, don't they?
Especially for experienced
adventurers.
They faced guards before they
breached fortifications.
Typically a coordinated party
can make short work of that
initial resistance.
You feel competent in control.
Exactly.
It's the standard opening for
many fantasy conflicts.
It gives players that feeling of
competence, makes them believe
they are the powerful heroes
they often are.
The initial success provides
that brief, intoxicating rush,
maybe lulling them into a
dangerous overconfidence.
For a moment, it really looked
like the usual script 3 battered
adventurers carving through
lesser foes.
You can always feel their
initial confidence, right?
That familiar rhythm, that
comfortable sense of we've got
this.
Thinking they'd clear the
manner, deal with a Reeve, get
back to the dress.
Exactly.
But that confidence, that
expectation of a normal heroic
narrative, it was about to be
brutally shattered by Valaki's
unique and relentless brand of
oppression.
And what's absolutely crucial to
understand here, what the source
highlights so brilliantly, is
that Valaki is not a dungeon
full of expendable cobalts.
That line is incredibly
important.
Why so crucial?
Because this isn't a simple hack
and slash scenario.
The enemies aren't just cannon
fodder easily overcome by
superior heroic might.
The nature of the opposition
here fundamentally changes the
dynamic.
It's not about clearing rooms,
it's about being systematically
dismantled, facing an enemy that
doesn't just attack your hit
points, but your morale, your
resources, your very will to
fight.
And the source details that
relentless pressure Valakis
defenses brought and almost
suffocating weight every door
led to more resistance guards,
wardens, spells of necrotic
energy that nod at hit points in
morale.
Nod.
That's a good word for it.
Draining.
Yeah, spiritual weapons floating
down hallways like haunted
blades appearing out of nowhere.
It's not just more enemies, it's
the type of enemies, the
debilitating nature of their
attacks.
Chronic energy doesn't just cut
or burn, it gnaws, A draining,
demoralizing effect, slowly
chipping away, leaving you
weakened, despairing.
And those spiritual weapons
conjured by the Wardens, blades
of pure magic energy flying
independently, constantly hairy
and constantly whittling down,
creating this multi front
assault that makes it impossible
to focus.
So sheer numbers combined with
these unique debilitating
abilities.
Creates almost insurmountable
wall of opposition.
The source describes it
clinically.
Right.
Push here, heal there.
One warden cornered and slain,
another hurled out a window by
thunderous smite.
But then it immediately
clarifies the grim reality.
The tempo was wrong.
We weren't clearing the board,
we were being worn down.
This perfectly illustrates the
Borovian combat philosophy.
It doesn't fight fair.
It exhausts you, then punishes
desperation.
This isn't a battle of skill
against skill, it's a battle of
attrition against overwhelming
regenerating force.
Your resources are finite.
Exactly.
Your spells, your healing, your
stamina, your mental fortitude.
Finite.
There's Backed by the city's
endless supply of recruits and
Strad's pervasive influence,
They seem endless.
They're designed to grind you
down, making every small victory
feel like it costs a monumental
amount, slowly draining your
hope until you're left with
nothing but despair.
It's a cruel, systematic
approach to warfare, one that
rarely favors the heroic charge.
And this grinding dissent?
It was made worse by some
critical strategic pitfalls.
Classic errors, really, but in
Barovia they become magnified
into fatal flaws.
The source is very direct about
these.
First we split the party chasing
the secretary.
The Cardinal Sin never split the
party.
Yeah, especially not there.
Why is it it's so bad there?
It's.
A classic, often fatal mistake
in D&D, but especially in
hostile environments where
you're outnumbered like this,
splitting your forces
immediately reduces your
combined strength, your ability
to support each other.
It isolates individuals, makes
them vulnerable to being
overwhelmed, picked off.
In a place like Milwaukee, where
enemy numbers are vast and
tactics ruthless, splitting up
isn't just a mistake, it's an
open invitation for disaster.
Turns the cohesive unit into two
vulnerable, less effective
fragments.
OK, then we bottlenecked
ourselves in a hallway.
Another tactical misstep,
particularly against an enemy
with ranged attacks.
Area of effects, bells, or like
you're a female.
Endless supply of reinforcements
bottlenecking.
Let's a numerically superior foe
concentrate their attacks on a
confined space.
Turns a narrow corridor into a
killing zone.
No room to maneuver.
Exactly.
It eliminates your ability to
maneuver, to flank, to spread
out, to avoid damage.
It essentially traps you, makes
you easy targets.
You trade tactical flexibility
for maybe momentary progress.
A trade.
Barovia will always, always
punish.
And finally, a core error often
seen when heroes fall We
underestimated how strong the
Lockie's Wardens were.
This is such a crucial lesson in
any high stakes scenario, game
or real life.
Underestimating an opponent's
capabilities, especially when
they have unique powers like
necrotic magic and devilish
backing, it can be catastrophic.
You can't just fight harder when
the enemy doesn't play fair,
when they have tactical and
magical advantages beyond what
you initially perceive.
They don't just want you low on
HP.
They want you cornered,
exhausted, demoralized,
convinced of your own impending
failure.
They exploit everything.
They exploit your tactical
errors, your dwindling
resources, your diminishing
hope.
This isn't about overcoming a
challenge through sheer will.
It's about surviving a system
system designed to break you.
It's a crucial lesson for any
learner.
Accurate intelligence about your
opposition is just as important
as your own strength, and lack
thereof can quickly lead to an
irreversible downfall.
So as the party was being worn
down, strategically
outmaneuvered, the true master
of this section of Awlaki makes
his entrance not with a bang,
but with this chilling
professional precision.
The source described it at last.
They battered through the
barricade of study and to the
Reeves.
And this is where the nature of
the antagonist becomes truly
chilling, even more so because
he's so utterly mundane in his
evil.
The Reeve Ernst Larnak.
He's in some grand theatrical
villain with a booming laugh,
no.
Flowery speeches.
No, not a noble with flowery
speeches, not a gibbering
cultist.
He's just a cold professional
sword poison bolts in the
unflinching confidence of a man
who knows he controls the city
outside those walls.
That's almost scarier.
It often is, isn't it?
This type of villain, a
calculating bureaucrat assassin,
is often far more terrifying
than a raving monster in a
horror setting.
He embodies systemic,
institutional evil.
In horror, authority figures are
never just bureaucrats.
They're often the most insidious
threats because they operate
under the guise of order, law,
legitimate power.
He represents the crushing
weight of the system, not just
an individual threat.
His calm demeanor, his lack of
grandstanding, it only amplifies
his menace.
And his tactics were just as
chillingly calculated, devoid of
any heroic posturing.
He baited us with the
secretary's cowardice.
He used cover, crossbow fire,
and the promise of
reinforcements like weapons as
sharp as his blade.
He's not relying on raw power.
No, it's psychological
manipulation, tactical
positioning, and the
overwhelming numerical advantage
from his control of the city.
A cold clinical approach to
killing.
A true professional of tyranny.
That's the mark of a truly
dangerous adversary, especially
in Barovia.
He's not fighting for glory,
he's fighting to eliminate a
threat to his authority, his
order.
His confidence comes not just
from his own martial skill, but
from the full machinery of
Valaki.
He commands the guards, the
wardens, the bells, the very
fear of the populace.
He leveraged the environment,
the fear of his subordinates,
the very structure of the city
to his advantage.
Turning the manner into a
meticulously designed trap makes
him far more formidable than a
brute force antagonist.
He's playing chess while the
heroes are playing checkers, and
he always has the next three
moves planned.
And then came Surin's fatal
move.
The paladin and a desperate,
maybe overconfident attempt used
Misty Step, a short range
teleport spell.
Ah.
Misty Step.
Great spell usually.
Usually, the source says, great
for slipping past danger,
terrible if you teleport into
danger.
The irony here is just palpable.
A powerful tactical spell
designed for evasion or precise
positioning, used in a moment of
extreme desperation and
overestimation, leading directly
to doom.
He misty stepped into the room.
He got a blade in the back for
his trouble.
What stands out to you about
this moment of critical
misjudgment?
What broader lessons does it
offer about decision making
under pressure?
What's profoundly illustrated
here is how a spell which in
almost any other circumstance
would be a brilliant tactical
advantage, a moment of quick,
decisive action becomes an
instant liability.
Why?
Because of a critical lack of
complete information and
situational awareness.
He teleported blind.
Essentially, yes.
Soren, in that desperate moment,
likely saw an opening, a way to
bypass obstacles to directly
engage the threat, maybe finally
make a decisive strike against
the Reeve.
But he teleported into an
unknown space, blind to the
immediate dangers within that
room.
He didn't know if there were
other traps, other enemies, or
precisely where the Reeve was
positioned for a counter attack.
It highlights the critical
importance of assessing the
environment, gathering
intelligence, understanding the
full scope of a situation before
committing to any bold move,
especially in a hostile setting
like Barovia.
A stark reminder A.
Stark reminder that even the
most powerful abilities can be
turned against you if used
without foresight or a complete
understanding of the risks.
It wasn't just a misstep, it was
a gamble born of desperation.
A gamble that demonstrated the
ultimate cost of poor
situational awareness in a fight
where the enemy plays by
different much rules.
And the Reeves response was
swift, merciless, utterly devoid
of any romanticized notion of
combat.
That's when the Reeves showed us
what a Borovian boss fight looks
like.
No honor duel.
No fair challenge.
Coup de grace execution.
This is where Borovia truly
excels in its cruelty, and it's
a deliberate narrative choice.
A coup de grace isn't just a
killing blow, it's a deliberate
act of extinguishing hope and
dignity and execution of an
already incapacitated or
vulnerable foe.
Stripped of heroic agency.
Completely.
It signifies absolute victory,
the complete and utter
dehumanization of the opponent.
Soren, a paladin of celestial
blood, a radiant hammer of
justice quote, cut down and
finished off while his friends
watched helplessly from the
hall.
There was no glorious last
stand, no epic confrontation, no
noble sacrifice in battle, just
the cold, efficient, almost
bureaucratic termination of a
threat.
This underscores Borovia's
unique horror.
It strips away the very idea of
a noble death, reduces it to a
pragmatic, brutal elimination.
Anticlimactic.
Profoundly anticlimactic.
And then that leaves no room for
heroic narrative or solace, only
the lingering taste of defeat,
powerlessness, and profound
grief.
It leaves you feeling hollow
rather than inspired.
The aftermath is just as a grim
an image that just sears itself
into your mind.
Soren's body was claimed by the
lackey's wardens, his celestial
blood spilled in a study reeking
of fear and bureaucracy.
Divine blood mixing with mundane
dread.
Exactly.
The divine, the heroic, the
pure, reduced to a mere
casualty, a piece of evidence,
His sacred blood staining the
mundane, corrupt carpet of an
enforcer's office.
The imagery itself is
devastating.
A final insult is a sacred
calling.
So with Cern's brutal,
inglorious end, his companions
faced an impossible, gut
wrenching choice.
A cinematic last stand, a
valiant but almost certainly
fatal charge against
overwhelming odds, or the
smarter, crueler thing.
Indeed, the source states
Bradley and Trackser could have
made the cinematic last stand.
They could have died beside him.
And this is what we as an
audience are conditioned to
expect from heroic narratives,
isn't it?
Loyalty, Sacrifice.
Going down, fighting to the last
breath, side by side with your
fallen comrade.
The stuff of legends.
The noble death.
But in Barovia, those
expectations are constantly
upended, not just for the
heroes, but for anyone
witnessing their story.
The narrative actively resists
that romanticized archetype.
And what they did, with a
tactical and emotional weight
that just can't be overstated,
was the smarter, crueler thing.
They fled.
Ran for their lives.
Through the back stairs, into
alleys, slipping to the Blue
Water Inn like rats escaping the
flood.
A desperate, undignified escape,
far from any heroic retreat.
They ran and.
This highlights the immense
weight of that decision.
Why is survival sometimes the
crueler choice in a narrative
sense, despite being tactically
sound?
Because it means leaving a
comrade behind.
It means prioritizing your own
life over the shared narrative
of dying together, of upholding
that unbreakable bond of
companionship.
It goes against the very grain
of heroic self sacrifice.
And yet in Borovia it is often
the only choice if you want to
continue fighting another day,
if you want any hope of
affecting the larger conflict.
It forces a harsh pragmatism
that leaves a profound emotional
and psychological scar.
A burden they'll carry.
Absolutely.
The decision to flee, while
strategically correct for long
term survival, undoubtedly
carried an immense emotional
burden for Radley and Tracidor,
a burden that will haunt them
for the remainder of their time
in Borovia and maybe beyond.
It is a constant reminder of
what they had to forsake to
live.
It was undeniably the right move
for survival, yes, but it left
Soren's body behind, claimed by
Valaki's wardens, his celestial
blood spilled in a study reeking
of fear and bureaucracy.
That image a divine being, a
beacon of hope, reduced to a
mere casualty.
His body seized as evidence, his
very essence mingling with the
stench of fear and official
corruption.
The contrast is devastating.
And this is where the Source
delivers one of its most
powerful and sobering
statements.
That's Borovia.
Not a place where heroes die in
glory, but where they're reduced
to evidence bags in a Tyrants
investigation.
Evidence Act.
This raises an important, deeply
unsettling question.
What does it mean for heroes to
be treated like evidence?
It means their lives, their
struggles, their very existence
are stripped of any epic
significance.
They become mere objects, data
points in a larger oppressive
system.
Their death isn't a sacrifice,
it's an inconvenience, a problem
to be neatly catalogued and
filed away.
It's the ultimate
dehumanization, the final
indignity, removing all
romanticism from death and
replacing it with cold
bureaucratic efficiency.
Which is, I think, a truly
terrifying and uniquely Borovian
form of horror.
Their story is not a legend,
it's a police report.
The question naturally arises
then, both for the players and
for us, the audience.
Why did we let Soren die?
And the source is clear in its
answer.
We didn't.
We fought as hard as we could.
But it acknowledges the
convergence of factors.
Right, it points to the tactical
errors.
We split the party chasing the
secretary.
We bottlenecked ourselves in a
hallway.
We underestimated how strong
Valaki's words were and Soren's
misty step into a closed room
with no backup.
These aren't just minor
mistakes, they're critical
judgments that, when combined
with the Reeve being a deadly
assassin who knew when to finish
the job and the overwhelming
attritional nature of the
lackey's defenses, it created an
impossible situation.
The source articulates that
sometimes in D&D, your character
dies not because you gave up,
but because the dice, the
tactics, and the cruel logic of
the story all converge.
This isn't about blaming the
players or the characters.
It's about acknowledging the
systemic, almost inevitable
difficulty of the environment.
It wasn't just bad luck, no.
And this raises another
important point.
In Borovia, the land itself
seems to conspire to make those
moments stink, to magnify every
mistake.
This isn't just bad luck, it's
part of the settings malevolent
design.
The valley is actively working
against you, subtly and
sometimes not so subtly,
twisting circumstances,
magnifying every tactical error,
turning every weakness into a
fatal flaw.
It seeks to break your spirit as
much as your body.
Even though Strad himself never
appeared in this session, never
stepped out of the shadows for a
chilling monologue, his presence
was palpable, wasn't it?
His shadow stretching over every
grim detail, every calculated
act of oppression.
The source makes it clear his
fingerprints were everywhere.
What's fascinating here is how
his absence makes his presence
even more palpable.
Yeah, and terrifying.
Strad is the ultimate puppet
master of the supreme architect
of this prison realm.
Falaki's collapse, Walker's
rise, the Devil amulet wardens,
all or his order imposed on
chaos.
He doesn't need to be physically
present to exert his will.
His machinations are woven into
the very fabric of Barothian
society, turning its denizens
into pawns, its cities into
extensions of his will.
Controlling events from afar.
Exactly setting up the
conditions for despair and
tragedy.
This unseen, pervasive control
makes him even more terrifying
that a monster you can just
confront with a sword.
He's the architect of the entire
nightmare, and every act of
despair, every loss ultimately
serves to strengthen his
dominion, feeding his insatiable
hunger for control and misery.
You're never truly fighting
against Strad, you're simply
moving within the parameters he
has already defined.
And the consequences of this
session?
They just ripple outwards,
creating unfinished business
that will undoubtedly haunt the
survivors.
Radley and Traxidor that
Abbott's quest for a wedding
dress is still hanging over us,
now soured by the blood spilled
in its pursuit.
It's tainted now.
Completely.
It's no longer just a strange,
macabre Aaron.
It's tainted by a profound
tragedy, by the loss of a dear
friend, making it an even
heavier, more emotionally
fraught burden.
And this feeds directly into
that cycle of despair that
defines Barofia.
Every move we make circles back
to Strawd.
Every death feeds his legend.
Soren's fall now becomes one
more ghost in the valley, adding
to the oppressive history and
legend of Perovia.
If we connect this to the bigger
picture, it's about the valley
itself being a character
designed to break spirits.
Every tragedy isn't just a set
back, it's a sacrifice that
fuels Stride's power, reinforces
his control, deepens that
pervasive sense of hopelessness
that defines life and death in
Barovia.
The Valley absorbs the defeats.
It absorbs these losses of light
and hope, making it stronger,
making the prospect of true
freedom seem ever more distant,
unreachable.
Soren's death isn't an end.
It's another brick in the wall
of Stroud's eternal prison.
OK, let's try to unpack some of
the deeper, more profound
lessons we can draw from this
intense deep dive into Valaki
Heresy and the fall of Surin
Ironwood.
This session really exemplifies
a unique storytelling approach,
doesn't it?
One that actively, aggressively
subverts typical heroic fantasy
tropes.
Challenges are very notions.
What a hero is what victory
looks like.
Absolutely.
This session is a master class
in narrative inversion.
It offers a critical lens
through which to view
traditional heroic arcs.
Consider the core tenets.
Divine power, which should be a
hero's greatest asset, becomes a
glaring liability attracting
persecution, right?
The wings.
Authority figures, often seen as
sources of order and justice,
are revealed to be deadly
assassins, meticulous agents of
tyranny, and death itself is
rendered inglorious, devoid of
any noble sacrifice or inspiring
final stand.
This profound subversion isn't
just for shock value, it's
integral to Borovius thematic
core.
It forces both the characters
and us, the audience, to
constantly question our
preconceived notions of heroism,
power, justice.
When the rules are upside down.
Exactly when the very rules of
heroism are turned upside down,
when good intentions lead to
tragic ends, it begs the
question, what truly defines a
hero in such a brutal,
unforgiving world?
It suggests it's about finding
strength not in conquest but in
enduring and simply surviving,
in making those crueler choices
necessary to continue.
This challenges us to look
beyond simplistic narratives and
appreciate the depth and
resonance of stories that
explore moral ambiguity and the
high cost of principle.
And for you, the listener, how
does understanding these
narrative inversions enrich your
appreciation of storytelling,
whether it's in games, books,
films, it changes your
expectations, right?
It makes you look for the cracks
in the heroic facade, the hidden
cruelties beneath the surface.
It had so much depth.
It really does, allowing for
stories that resonate on a far
more complex emotional level
than simple good versus evil
tales.
It teaches us that true impact
can come from challenging what
we expect, creating a more
sophisticated, thought provoking
narrative experience.
It's about building a world
where every choice is fraught
with consequence, and where the
most powerful moments often
arise from loss, not victory.
And beyond the narrative, this
session also offers incredibly
potent strategic insights.
Lessons that really transcend
the gaming table apply to a
multitude of real world
scenarios.
Like what?
Well, the importance of
intelligence, for one.
Knowing your enemy's true
strength.
That Valachi's wardens were
formidable cultists.
That the Reeve was a cold,
calculating assassin, not just
some bumbling bureaucrat.
That's absolutely critical.
The party's underestimation
proved fatal.
Applies anywhere.
Absolutely.
This translates directly to any
challenge you face.
Always assess your opposition
accurately.
Don't assume.
Gather all available
information.
Understand their capabilities,
motivations, resources, because
underestimating a threat can
lead to catastrophic
consequences, whether you're in
AD and D dungeon or a boardroom
negotiation.
And then there's team cohesion,
positioning.
Exactly.
The dangers of splitting the
party, of bottlenecking
yourselves in a hallway against
an overwhelming force.
These aren't just D&D cliches,
they're universal lessons in
coordinated action.
Shows how quickly a strong force
can be neutralized through poor
tactical choices.
So stay together, communicate.
In any collaborative endeavor,
whether it's a team project at
work or a complex family
decision, maintaining clear
communication, staying united,
understanding how you're
positioning literal and
metaphorical affects your
collective strength Absolutely
vital.
A strong team can be rendered
vulnerable if its members are
isolated or poorly deployed.
In Sarin's Missy step.
Yes, that highlights the
critical importance of assessing
risk and understanding the
environment before committing to
a bold move.
He had a powerful ability but
used it in a blind rush,
teleporting into an unknown
space with no backup, leading
directly to disaster.
This teaches us that even the
most potent tools or brilliant
ideas, when deployed without
proper environmental awareness
or a solid support structure,
can lead to unforeseen and
devastating consequences.
It's a crucial lesson in
strategic thinking.
Pause.
Evaluate the full context.
Consider potential
repercussions.
Ensure you have a fall back or
support before making that
critical leap.
Universal Lessons.
Absolutely universal lessons in
strategy and decision making,
applicable far beyond the gaming
table.
This deep dive shows us in
vivid, brutal detail the
consequences when these
principles are ignored.
But this deep dive isn't just
about mechanics or strategy, is
it?
It's profoundly about the
emotional weight of loss, that
crueler decision to flee, to
save themselves but leave
Soren's body behind.
It underscores the grim reality
of survival in Borovia.
It's a decision that, while
tactically sound, carries an
immense emotional toll, a deep,
lasting scar on Radley and
Tracidor.
How does this kind of
storytelling resonate more
deeply with us, the audience?
I think it resonates so deeply
because it's raw, it's real.
It's the kind of loss that isn't
mitigated by glory or a sense of
noble sacrifice.
It's messy, it's brutal, and
it's deeply human.
This kind of storytelling
doesn't just entertain, it
evokes profound empathy.
It forces us to confront
uncomfortable truths about what
it means to survive in a truly
unforgiving world.
It tells us that sometimes the
hardest choices are the ones
that save your life but leave a
piece of your soul or the memory
of a fallen friend behind.
Painful compromises.
Exactly.
It reminds us that stories of
suffering we told with such raw
honesty and unslinching detail
could be incredibly powerful in
teaching us about the limits of
human endurance, the true cost
of principle, and the high price
of hope when it must be bought
with a painful compromises.
And so this deep dive into
Valaki heresy and the fall of
Surin Ironwood leaves us with,
well, a profound understanding.
Barovia is a land where survival
is the highest victory.
Glory is a luxury rarely
afforded.
Soren's story is a powerful
testament to the crushing,
systematic cruelty of this
cursed valley, where even divine
light can be extinguished
without ceremony, without the
dignity of a hero's farewell.
As Radley and Tracidor regroup
at the Blue Water Inn, their
friends celestial Blood still
standing, the floor of the
Reeves study, claimed as
evidenced by the very forces
they sought to defy.
We're left to wonder, aren't we?
Will they recover from this
profound loss?
Can they?
Will the memory of Surin spur
them to even greater, more
desperate acts of heroism?
Will they dare to bargain for
his body or risking everything
again for the fallen?
Or will Strad simply keep him,
turning Soren's tragic end into
yet another pawn in his eternal,
merciless game, a grim warning
edged into the very fabric of
Borovia?
It really encourages us to
reflect, doesn't it, on how
profoundly environments can
shape destiny, how even the
purest intentions can be
twisted, and how, even in the
face of overwhelming despair,
the choices made by characters
or by us to find their legacy
not just for themselves, but for
those who survive to tell the
tale.
The.
Echoes will certainly continue.
The echoes of CERN Ironwood's
fall will undoubtedly shape the
future of his companions, and
perhaps the very fate of Borovia
itself.
Thank you for joining us on this
profound, albeit dark, journey
into the shadows of Borovia.
Until next time, keep diving
deep.